So what I'm going to talk about,
uh,
today and Thursday is, uh, two topics,
which what I hope to do is sort of bring
together some of the information that
we've been talking about over the
course of the term. And to do that,
I want to focus on two areas today,
talk about cancer and a big subject.
And so we'll just scratch the surface.
But the main point that I want to make
is how some of the technologies that
we've been talking about
over the course of the term,
or having an impact on cancer,
a diagnosis and care,
and to sort of point to
some areas that were,
where they'll likely be more progress
and opportunities for progress in the
future. And then on Thursday
we'll do the same thing,
but talking about the subject
of artificial organs and
one that we've brushed on
a couple of times through the semester.
But just try to try to spend some
focus time, uh, on it, on, um, on,
uh, Thursday section meeting
on a Thursday afternoon.
Uh, we'll do a course review.
So I'll be there for each, uh,
for each of the sections.
And I'll just be leading a
discussion about what we've
covered in the course and,
and uh, what kinds of things
will be a on the final. Okay.
Any questions?
Okay.
So, uh, you know, uh,
what's described here on this slide that
cancer is a deadly and unfortunately
not uncommon a disease.
And these are some statistics from 2006,
uh,
collected by the American cancer society.
And one of the things that we do fairly
well as a nation now is keep track of,
uh, of uh, cancer, uh, cases and progress.
And this has been an important part of
our learning about where cancers occur,
what are the causes and what
treatments work and what don't.
And the American cancer society has been
a big part of that effort to collect
information on where cancers
occur in the country, in what,
in what people and what age groups and to,
and to provide that information for
people that are working on research for
cancer. So this just summarizes
some of that information.
For 2006 new cases of cancer,
you can see a million
over a million new cases,
deaths from cancer.
About,
about half a million and a roughly
equal between males and females.
And here's some common,
uh,
some common types of cancer occurring
in a female's of breast cancer in both
males and females, lung cancer and
you know, males only prostate cancer.
And so the statistics are alarming,
right?
If you look at the number of
deaths that are caused by cancer,
and if you want to
learn more sort of that,
I urge you to go to the American Cancer
Society website, which is listed here,
but just a few facts about cancer that
you probably know something about this.
It's now the most common cause of death
in the u s and that's true in many
developed countries.
Cancer and heart disease have been neck
and neck in terms of the number one
cause of deaths in developed
countries for many years now. And,
and it looks like a cancer is winning.
And we'll talk about that in a,
in a minute.
Cancers caused by new t mutations
in genes that control cell growth.
So you know that a cancer or formation
of a tumor is an unwanted or uncontrolled
growth of cells. Cell Division. Uh,
runs a muck and cells don't stop dividing
under circumstances where they're
supposed to.
And so you get a mass is formed in
that mass is it represents the unwanted
growth of cells,
the mutations that cause cancer
that caused these defects.
And cell growth can be either
inherited or environmental.
We know that there are things in
the environment that cause cancer.
Some viruses can cause cancers.
So the most,
one of the clearest links is
between a human papilloma virus,
a sexually transmitted disease and uh,
and cervical cancer in women.
And so there is a new vaccine
for HPV human papilloma virus,
and it's expected that this vaccine which
will prevent spread of the virus will
also significantly reduce cancer
cases. Um, other kinds of, uh,
viruses are linked to liver cancers.
For example,
sample chemicals can also, uh, in the
environment can also cause cancer.
And we'll talk more about
that in a minute. Uh,
but most cancers also involved
some, uh, some genetic, uh, changes,
uh, that can be either
acquired or inherited. And so,
you know,
also that a cancer can run in families,
the risk of certain kinds of cancers.
There's a genetic basis for that.
In the u s the lifetime risk of
cancer is one and two for men.
So half of men will have some kind of
a cancer and one in three for women.
And so that's pretty impressive.
A number.
Um, the age adjusted mortality rate for
cancer is about the same in the 21st
centuries.
It was 50 years ago.
That is the rate of death from cancer
hasn't changed very much in the last 50
years.
And this,
in spite of the fact that there's been
a lot of attention to cancer in learning
more about cancer and its causes,
the basic biology and in trying to
design new methods for diagnosing and
treating cancer, but overall
deaths haven't changed very much.
We've made progress in certain kinds
of tumors, uh, but, but not in others.
And this just,
I think reflects the fact that both
cancer is a heterogeneous disease.
You know, that it occurs in a
variety of sites throughout the body.
But in each of those sites, cancers can
be quite different. It's not one disease,
but it's a family of diseases. And
because of that, it's been hard to, uh,
to make progress in treatment because
all of them have slightly different
characteristics.
Yeah.
Uh, this just illustrates that
last point a little more clearly.
Changing US death rates by
cause from 1950 to 2003.
So over that period, deaths from
heart disease went down dramatically.
Deaths from cerebrovascular diseases,
so deaths of the circulatory
system in the brain.
So this is mainly stroke and aneurysms
down dramatically deaths from infectious
diseases. We talked about
vaccines several weeks ago,
which has had a big impact on,
on mortality from infectious diseases.
Also down over that years, deaths from
cancer stays about the same. All right.
So, uh, so while we've
made great progress,
we're not yet at the point where we're
changing the outcomes from a cancer very
dramatically.
Okay.
I mentioned a few minutes ago that,
uh,
exposure to chemicals can cause
cancer and you know, this,
and one of the most well known,
uh,
exposures that's clearly a cause
of cancer is tobacco use. Uh,
so this is tobacco use, uh, mainly
thinking about cigarette smoking. Uh,
but, uh, the same thing could be true
of a, of any kind of tobacco use, uh,
smoking cigars or chewing tobacco also
causes cancer because the chemicals in a
cigarette smoke or in a
tobacco in particular, um, uh,
some of the tars that are associated with
a smoking cause cancer of the lung in
particular. And this was first noticed
by looking at epidemiological data.
We talked about public
health and epidemiology a few
weeks ago where you look at
how diseases appear in populations and
you try to figure out why things are
changing. Um, so here's,
as cigarettes were
consumed more in the US,
you can see the trend in cigarette
consumption going up over, um,
over a time from 1900 to 1950.
And then lagging behind that by
about a period of 30 years, uh,
is an a dramatic increase in lung cancer,
uh,
first among men and then among women.
And the reason for that is
because cigarette smoking
was initially more popular
among men than among women. Uh, but,
but advertising and the women's movement
changed that cigarette smoking became
something that everybody could do.
It was acceptable in polite
society for women to smoke.
And they were targeted by
manufacturers of cigarettes.
Special cigarettes were made for
women. Um, there's special in some way,
but not in their ability to cause cancer.
They're all the same.
And so female lung cancer still rise.
And you can see we've made some progress
in male lung cancer mainly by reducing
the number of smokers. Uh, but
that hasn't yet happened in uh,
in women.
So evidence first came from epidemiology,
but then after it was realized that there
was an association between cigarette
smoking and cancer,
then you can start to look more closely
and try to figure out what the molecular
cause of it is.
And we now know quite a lot about how
the chemicals in smoke caused these sorts
of malignant transformations
in cells that lead to cancer.
The evidence is pretty clear.
So the main point that exposure to
chemicals can cause, uh, cancer.
Uh, this, just to try to put in
perspective, uh, where cancer occurs,
what are the most frequent causes of
cancer that lead to death and in both men
and women? Lung cancer is
number one. After that,
it changes the top three and men being
lung, colon, and prostate in women,
lung,
breast and colon and accounting for just
those top three of the large majority
of cancers. Cancer of the
pancreas is much less common.
But because it's so difficult to detect,
and we'll talk about methods
of detection, uh, but um,
the pancreas is an organ
that's deep within your body
and it's hard to find when
things are going wrong with it.
Uh,
so because it's difficult to
detect cancer of the pancreas,
it very frequently leads to death.
And of course this is in the news now
because this is the kind of cancer that
Patrick Swayze has.
Life expectancy when you have a pancreatic
cancer is a life expectancy is very
low because it's usually an
advanced stage when it's discovered
cancer cells are different.
So what makes all these cancers
at different sites a similar is,
is the similar characteristics that
the cells that form cancers have.
And I mentioned already that one of the
things that characterizes cancer is that
cells divide abnormally.
They divide usually more rapidly.
We talked about several weeks ago when
we were talking about cell culture,
we talked about cells that you would
isolate from tissue and they would grow at
a rate of about by doubling their
number every day if you maintain them in
culture, cancer cells can grow much
faster than that. Uh, so they've,
they have mechanisms for,
for dividing very rapidly.
More importantly,
probably they don't stop proliferating
when they're supposed to write. You know,
from what we've talked about before,
that there are cells that are continually
dividing and reproducing within your
body cells in your intestinal tract.
For example, cells in the liver,
cells in the kidney continually
dividing cells in your skin,
but ordinarily your skin stays the
same size that it is because cells are
dividing.
But they know when to stop
and they stopped when they
reached the right density,
the right shape. They know where they're
supposed to be. Cancer cells don't.
They continue to divide even when they
get signals that they're supposed to stop
dividing. And so because
of this tumors form, right?
Abnormal growths,
the organ of origin a becomes
larger than it ordinarily would.
They generally don't respond to signals
that are provided by neighboring cells.
We talked about cell communication and
how important that was for the life of a
tissue that for your liver to be your
liver and your brain to be your brain.
They don't just have
the right cells there,
but they have cells that are communicating
in the right way and there's a loss
of that normal, uh, molecular
communication when you have cancer,
they don't differentiate normally
but tend to remain as immature.
Di differentiated are undifferentiated
cells. So what's this like?
This is like we talked about stem cells.
Stem cells are less mature
than, than uh, than uh,
differentiated tissue cells.
They grow rapidly.
Both stem cells,
which self renew and cancer cells,
they don't form mature types of cells.
And there's a lot of linkages now
known between stem cells and cancer.
And some people think that within any
individual tumor, there are cancer,
stem cells that really are the
most important ones to treat.
Because if you get rid of even the bulk
of cancer cells without getting rid of
these very few stem like cells in cancers,
tumors will regrow again.
So normal differentiation
like stem cells is, uh,
is a problem with cancer cells.
They don't adhere readily to other
cells and extra sailor matrix.
They do not become
specialized in dy. And, uh,
because cells in your skin are
continually going through not just birth,
not just growth of new cells,
but death.
There's skin cells that are dying and
being shed from your body all the time.
Cancer cells don't undergo those normal
processes of cell death that lead to
regulation of a tissue structure.
So if a cancer forms,
it tends to go through different
stages and that this cell, for example,
in this, um, in this, uh,
tissue is a premalignant cell.
If it becomes malignant, it we'll start
dividing and growing out of control.
And you can see that here,
that uh,
that tumor that forms at the initial site
or the site of the origin of a cancer
is called the primary tumor.
These tumors, if they grew,
um, would ordinarily stop at a
size of about one millimeter,
you know, very small,
you wouldn't even be able to notice them.
Maybe if they're only a
millimeter or so in size.
And they don't grow beyond that as a cell
mass because they can't get nutrients,
oxygen, glucose, the things that
the cell needs, amino acids,
the things that it needs in order to
produce new cells can't get in because
those are normally provided by the
bloodstream. And when the cells,
when a cell is just dividing out of
control, there's no blood supply, right?
So many people think that,
uh,
that tumor size would be limited.
Cancer wouldn't be such a problem
except for the fact that cancers at this
stage, as they moved from this
primary stage two invasive cancer,
they develop an ability to stimulate
the growth of blood vessels.
And so now you can see blood vessels
are growing into and through this tumor,
they develop their own blood supply and
they're able to get nutrients readily.
And this is when the growth of the
tumor really starts to take off.
So we'll talk about some therapies that
block this process of new tumor growth
called angiogenesis.
And many people think if you could block
that process selectively in tumors,
then you could halt all
tumors to a very small size.
That would not cause, uh, problems.
Okay.
A Sec.
Uh,
an additional stage after angiogenesis
that some tumors can go through is a
process called metastasis.
And that's where tumor cells actually
leave their site of origin and travel to
other places in the body. And that's
shown schematically in this cartoon here,
a tumor cell entering the circulation,
it can flow through the circulation and
maybe get lodged at some distance site
and begin the process of tumor
formation at that distant site.
So this is obviously a bad thing,
uh,
because maybe you can treat the primary
tumor in a variety of different ways,
which we'll talk about in just a minute.
But once it begins to spread throughout
the body becomes much more difficult to
treat, right? You have not just one tumor,
but potentially hundreds or thousands of
tumors that are forming throughout the
body.
Okay.
So the treatment for tumors for cancer
depends very much on what stage it's at,
when it's identified.
And for every kind of cancer physicians,
oncologists have developed classification
methods for talking about to each
other about what stage the cancer is at.
And I'll just show you that in, um, in
an example of that in bladder cancer.
So you might have an initial stage here
which is called a t a and t is at the
tumor rating t for tumor.
So this is a,
this is a very small tumor that's
just confined to the lining.
When it gets larger, it's classified as
t one. When it gets up to stage t two,
it's starting to invade from the lining
of the bladder into the other tissues of
the bladder.
T three t four.
By the time it's got the
stage [inaudible] it's,
it's occupying not only the
whole, uh, the whole, uh,
thickness of the wall of the bladder,
but it started to invade other tissues
like the prostate as well. All right.
And so you can see that if you have a
tumor that's at one of these early stages,
local therapy might work,
surgery or radiation or local
chemotherapy, which we'll talk about.
But as it begins to invade other organs,
then it's becomes more difficult to treat.
Right?
And they can spread.
And I don't mean for you to,
tumors can spread and don't mean for
you to be able to see all this here.
But you can look at this.
These slides will be posted as a usual.
Not only can you classify the normal,
the the original site of the tumor,
and that's classifications of melanoma
from tee one up to t four and they're
defined here. But you can classify whether
it has spread locally to lymph nodes.
And that's these end stages here and
whether it has metastasized to different
sites.
And so ordinarily a physician
will classify a tumor
according to the tumor nodal
involvement,
metastasis classification that's
appropriate for that kind of tumor.
And this allows physicians
to say exactly where your,
where your cancer is at in development.
And we know because we've been
treating cancer for a long time now,
you can select a treatment that's most
likely to work for the stage that it's at.
And so this all to say that diagnosing
specifically where a cancer is at in its
development within a patient is very
important for deciding what kind of a
treatment is likely to
lead to a good outcome.
So one of the things that biomedical
engineers have worked very diligently on
over the last 50 years or so is designing
new methods for cancer diagnosis.
And we've talked about some of these as
we've gone through the course and I just
want to highlight them here.
We talked about x rays and using x
ray radiation to look inside the body.
And mammography is a special kind of ray
imaging that's used to look just at the
breasts, uh, to see if there are
abnormal tissues within the breast.
And this shows a normal,
uh, Mami a mammogram.
And this shows an abnormal mammogram
with some kind of a dense deposit here
that's not normal.
And so mammography is used to
screen for breast cancer, um,
and it's a very important, uh, screen. And
now women when they reach a certain age,
are recommended to have mammography a
certain number of times per year or per
decade. Uh, just to try to
detect cancers at an early stage.
So this is an example of biomedical
engineering for diagnosis. Uh,
pap smears also done during
routine pelvic exams in women. Uh,
where a swab is used to remove some
cells from the cervical region.
And then you can look at these cells
under the microscope and here's what a
normal pap smear would look like.
You can see the sales are flat,
they have small nuclei, uh, not
a lot of protein. And so the, uh,
the, uh, sales don't stain very darkly,
uh, malignant cells. On the other hand,
cells that indicate there might be
cancer present have larger nuclei,
more intense staining,
abnormal shapes.
And so someone who looks at cells from
cervical pap smears all the time can
quickly tell if there's the danger that
there might be a tumor growing within a
patient who's had a smear like this.
Now this requires a visit to
office and a procedure. A,
wouldn't it be nice if there were blood
tests that you could do for cancer?
If all the technologies we talked about,
we talked about Eliza's for example,
in all the ways that we can look into the
blood to try to see what chemicals are
present there.
If you could,
if you could find chemical signatures of
cancer that could be detected in blood
or in urine or in some other fluid from
the body, that would be a great thing.
And unfortunately there are too many
examples of that yet we don't know how to
do that very well.
We do know for prostate cancer and for
certain other kinds of cancers, there's,
there are molecules that
you can detect in the blood.
In prostate cancer there's
a very particular molecule
called prostate specific
antigen PSA, which if the levels
of PSA rise in your blood,
that's a sign that there's something
going wrong in your prostate and you get a
more a thorough exam.
So blood tests are available but only
for certain kinds of cancers and they're
not widely available yet.
Although we would like for them to be.
So if you have a high, if you're a
male and you have an abnormally high,
a prostate specific antigen
level in your blood,
you might get a more thorough
examination and you might use an,
and your physician might use an
approach like ultrasound guided biopsy.
And here if you can see
in this diagram here,
this is a much less pleasant experience
than a blood test. Uh, but there's a,
um, there's a device that's
inserted through the rectum
up to close to where the
prostate is and this device has an
ultrasound probe on it so you can look by
ultrasound into the,
into this region of the body,
identify where the prostate is
and even where, uh, where, uh,
a growth on the prostate might be.
And then a needle comes out from this
device and takes a small sample of tissue
and this tissue is then taken to the
laboratory and looked at in the same way
that a pap smear might be looked at.
And we talked about using optical
microscopy or using optical instruments to
probe inside the body into
cavities that we can't see.
And there's lots of technology available
for this now, including a sigmoid,
a scopes and colonoscopes,
which are fiber optic systems,
uh, that can be inserted into
the colon or, uh, and, and um,
and uh, can be, if
they're designed properly,
inserted very far up into the colon to
actually let you look through a lens at
what's happening on the
surface of the tissue.
And this has been a very important advance
in terms of identifying cancer of the
colon.
For example,
similar scopes are available to look in
the lung for a lung cancer and to look
in, um, in a variety of other, uh,
sites in the body to look for
cancer and other diseases. So, um,
so a lot of engineering technology has
been brought to bear on the problem of
diagnosing cancer and
diagnosing cancer early.
What do you do with a cancer
is, uh, is present? Well, the,
arguably the oldest form of
cancer therapy is surgery. Um,
and surgery is used for biopsy to
take small samples to see if a growth,
for example, is abnormal. If you have
an abnormal growth on your skin, the uh,
a surgeon might cut off some of that
tissue and send it to a laboratory for
analysis and, uh, to find
out if it's a cancer or not.
Also use for looking deeper in the
body surgery. His surgeries, uh,
used for prevention of cancer.
If you have abnormal gross
called polyps in the colon,
surgeon can remove those polyps and
prevent them from progressing into a more
serious disease. Polyps on their
own aren't necessarily a cancerous,
but they can develop into cancer.
There's an association with that.
And so why not remove them surgically
before they have the chance? Um,
and surgeries often remove,
used to remove local, uh,
tumors in the lung, in the brain,
the colon, uh, the prostate.
So, uh, surgery is a, is a well
established form of cancer treatment.
Radiation can also be
used to treat cancer.
And this relates to the subject of
imaging that we talked about several weeks
ago.
We talked about using electromagnetic
radiation because it can penetrate into
the body and using that to
take pictures of what's inside.
But we also talked about forms of
radiation that had biological effects.
We talked about ionizing radiation.
For example,
an ionizing radiation can
cause changes in the body,
right? So this is radiation
that's on the high frequency,
short wavelength end of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
So x rays or gamma rays,
um, high frequency,
small wavelength,
so they can penetrate through tissues
very easily and they can interact with
Adams and nuclei inside of the,
of the molecules inside your body.
So ionizing radiation,
these forms of high energy radiation have
biological effects and we talked about
one of those effects is that they
can cause the ejection or the, um,
a deviation of electrons
on Adam's within the skin.
And this,
these change,
these ionizations that occur as electrons
are ejected from Adam's within the
skin can cause a cell damage.
This kind of ionization
is happening all the time.
You go out in the sun and radiation
impinges on your skin. It causes some, uh,
some, uh, damage.
There are forms of ionizing radiation
present at low levels in the,
in the, uh, in the environment around us.
And ordinarily that causes no problem
because the cells in your body are able to
repair damage.
You have repair mechanisms
either by producing new
cells or by repairing the DNA
that gets damaged in
cells. Uh, you can, uh,
you can recover from
the damage that happens,
but if radiation continues to
be delivered to that tissue,
you can overwhelm the body's
ability to repair itself.
And you can actually cause sections
of tissues or cells within sections of
tissues to die. And that's the
basis for radiation therapy.
So this graph, uh, which is, uh,
which describes an experiment
that was done many decades ago,
shows how radiation can
be used to kill cells.
So this axis here shows a dose of
radiation that's delivered to sales and
culture.
So radiation is focused on a petri
dish that contains cells and then you,
you expose them to some
amount of radiation.
So the dose of radiation is
going up as you move this way,
and then you look to see how many
cells survive that procedure,
how many cells survive
this dose of radiation.
So let's look at a dose of
six grays. Here. Gyi is a,
D is a radiation unit called the
gray at this dose of six graze.
If you move up the scale here,
you'll kill all but 0.01 fraction
or 0.1% of bone marrow cells.
So you would kill most of the bone marrow
cells that were exposed by radiation
of this kind. You would kill, uh,
about 90% of sales from the breast and
you was killed even less of these other
kinds of cells here.
So that illustrates another point that
cells have different sensitivities to
radiation.
And if you know something about the
type of cells you're trying to treat by
radiation, then you can
adjust the dose that you give.
So you're killing only the
ones that you want, right?
But some cells are always going to be
susceptible cells of the bone marrow,
for example, very
susceptible to radiation. Um,
so how do you,
how do you avoid that problem that
you want to kill cells of the tumor,
but you don't want to kill cells that
are also sensitive to radiation and other
parts of the body.
You do that by just focusing the
radiation on the site that you want.
You do it by localizing where
the radiation is delivered.
And so biomedical engineers and physicists
have developed methods for external
beam radiation.
And these are devices that look somewhat
like the imaging systems we talked
about several weeks ago,
but they're delivering high doses of,
of ionizing radiation.
And you can see that perhaps that this
thing is on a cradle that swings back and
forth and there are, uh, lenses
in here to focus the radiation.
And so the position can move it to
whatever site that he wants in three
dimensions and focus the beam so it hits
only the tissue that you want to expose
to radiation.
Right?
And so these techniques depend very much
on computers and on mathematical models
of what the tissue looks
like inside your body.
They're guided by imaging methods,
uh,
but the idea is to deliver only
radiation at the site that you want to.
Can you do a perfect job?
No,
but you can do a pretty
good job in focusing the
radiation at the site that you
want. So this described a little bit
more in the chapter in your book.
Another way to get radiation delivered
only where you want is to put the
radiation source inside the
body in the location you want.
And that's called brachy therapy.
And this is an example of a prostate
tumor that's filled with what looked like
little stars here or a little bright dots.
Each one of these bright dots is a
small metal seed that's filled with a
radioactive material.
Those are implanted physically in the
tissue and then the tissue around it is
exposed to radiation.
It's a special kind of radiation that
only penetrates a certain depth in the
tissue.
And as it penetrates,
it delivers ionizing radiation
to all the cells around it.
And so you can see these, these, um,
these small seeds are arrayed throughout
the tissues so that you can treat it as
uniformly as possible. So
radiation can be used to, uh,
to uh, treat tumors. Uh,
another thing I wanted to show you on
this slide here is that some cells can be
made to be more sensitive to
radiation than they ordinarily are.
And that example shown here with
these human cells that have been, um,
that have been welded, they lack
the normal DNA repair mechanisms.
So cells that lack DNA repair mechanisms,
if you expose them to ionizing radiation,
they're much more sensitive because they
don't have the mechanisms to repair sub
lethal damage.
Right?
And so one important area of research
is trying to find drugs that you can
deliver that will accumulate in tumor
tissue to make them more sensitive to
radiation, which you then deliver
in the ways that I've described.
So there are a variety of different
approaches that are under study here for
delivering radiation more carefully,
more selectively to specific regions of
the body and to design drugs or other
strategies to make tumors more
sensitive to the radiation you deliver.
You know, about chemotherapy. Again,
this is a slide that I don't
intend for you to, uh, to, uh,
be able to read a on your,
in your leisure.
You can look at the slide when it's
posted and just gives you some idea of the
breadth of knowledge that we now
have about chemotherapy drugs.
There are many different classes of drugs
that have been developed and studied
and employed for treating cancer.
And most of these drugs work in a similar
fashion by interfering with DNA or by
interfering with the mechanisms by which
cells repair DNA so that you can halt
cell growth, right? If you crosslink
all the DNA inside of a cell,
it can't synthesize any more DNA and
then it can't divide and proliferate.
And that's, that's the basis of action
for many of these, although not all.
So I'll let you look at
those at your leisure.
But one of the problems with chemotherapy
is that these drugs have effect not
only on tumor cells,
but they have affects on normal cells.
So if you deliver chemotherapy
throughout the body,
not only do you have an effect on
the tumor and effect that you want,
but you have an effect on other tissues.
In particular,
the kinds of tissues where cell growth
controlled cell growth is an important
part of their physiology. So the
intestine, the bone marrow, your hair,
skin.
And so patients who have chemotherapy
often get digestive problems,
severe digestive problems,
they get anemia or infections because
they're not producing cells in their bone
marrow anymore.
They lose their hair because hair is
produced by cells that are dividing in the
skin.
They get rashes and other skin symptoms
because their skin isn't repairing and
remodeling and the normal
way. So you, you know this.
So one concept that has emerged over
the last 10 years or so is to deliver
chemotherapy drugs locally instead of
delivering them over the whole body.
And I gave you this example from my own
research lab a few weeks ago and we were
talking about drug delivery. But
just to remind you, here's a,
here's a situation where
there's a tumor in the brain.
And so this can be treated by surgery.
And in this case,
the surgeons were given
a drug delivery systems.
These were degradable polymer wafers
that were filled with high concentrations
of chemotherapy. So in the operating
room, after they remove the tumor,
they can place these drug
delivery systems in the brain.
The patient leaves the operating
room with most of the tumor removed.
And with high dose chemotherapy delivered
locally over a long period of time
after they leave the operating room.
So this should remind you of the brachy
therapy we talked about a few slides ago.
Instead of depositing a
dose of radiation in here,
we deposited a dose of drugs and deposited
in a way that these drugs could be
released slowly over time and hopefully
locally kill any residual tumor cells
that are remaining.
One of the most impressive,
impressive,
important and exciting new developments
over the last five years has been the
development of new chemotherapy agents
that work by mechanisms of action, uh,
that were not known previously.
And so this is an example of modern
biology and our understanding of cancer
biology in particular leading to the
design of drugs that are more specific to
cancers because they take advantage
of mechanisms that only cancer cells
typically use. All right. Uh,
so one of those is a drug called Gleevec.
And remember in the fourth week of
the class we've talked about cell
communication.
We talked about signal transduction and
how messages get from the outside of the
cell into the inside of the cell.
And we talked about how important a class
of signaling molecules called tyrosene
kinases were to creating
intracellular signals.
Well,
it turns out that certain kinds of tumors,
you use a special tyrosene
kinase called BCR Abl,
and that that tyrosene kinase can be
inhibited by a drug that was designed to
inhibit it called Gleevec.
Now this is one of the first examples
of what's called rational drug design.
In that biologists had identified this
particular tyrosene kinase and they knew
what was involved in signaling inside
certain kinds of cancers in particular a
certain kind of a lymphoma.
And they studied this molecule in its
molecular detail and developed a drug now
call Gleevec that would interfere with
the action of that molecule and interfere
with the action of that molecule and not
all the other tyrosene kinases that are
important for healthy cell
life and the rest of your body.
So this drug prevents kinase activity.
It does it by blocking
the binding site for ATP.
Remember that ATP was a second messenger.
That kinase is used in order
to phosphorolate, uh, protein.
So this is a,
this is an exciting example because it's
the first one of the first examples of
rational design of a drug at a very
specific specific molecular target inside
tumors. Now unfortunately
it's, it's limited.
Gleevec is limited in its use to only
a couple of subclasses of tumors that
express this a tyrosine
kinase at high concentrations.
But I think the idea of it is one
that can be translated outside.
Another new drug that's been developed in
the last few years is called Herceptin.
Herceptin is unique in a
number of different ways.
One is that it's an antibody and we
talked about the role of antibodies in the
immune response several weeks ago and
we talked about how vaccines are often
designed in order to get your body to
produce antibodies to an infectious
disease.
So you're familiar with the concept of
using antibodies to neutralize pathogens.
Here's an antibody that was designed to
bind to a receptor that appears only on,
uh,
cells in breast cancer.
And this receptor is called
her too. It's a form of, um,
of a growth factor receptor
that is particularly highly
expressed in some kinds
of breast cancers. And if you
deliver this molecule Herceptin,
it's an antibody which binds to this
receptor and prevents its normal function
and its normal function is to
signal breast cancer cells to grow.
So when this antibody binds,
it shuts off that growth signal that
the breast tumor cell is getting,
uh,
from this receptor.
It also promotes the immune response
to the tumor because you can imagine if
this is a breast cancer cell that has
lots of these receptor molecules on the
surface and you now
you put in an antibody,
you deliver an antibody which gets coated
on the surface and now this surface is
tagged, this sale is tagged for
recognition by your immune system.
And the immune system can, um, can, uh,
develop a response to this tumor as well.
So these are both exciting new
potential therapies for cancer.
They're real therapies for some cancer,
but point the way towards more broadly
applicable methods that might be used to
designing a chemotherapy agents.
The problem is that it takes a long time
and a lot of money and a lot of effort
in order to get from the point where you
design a new chemotherapy drug to the
point where it can be used in patients.
And so I thought I would end this lecture
by just reviewing a little bit about
that process and try to get you a sense
for why in practical terms there haven't
been more drugs developed for a
cancer over the past several decades.
And the process occurs in steps and I'm
going to look at it over a timescale of
about 20 years, uh, about 20 years here.
And it involves both testing in
vitro testing, in test tubes,
in a laboratory,
testing often in cell cultures to look
for drugs that have properties that you
think might make them useful for cancer.
And usually from the time
that you think about a drug,
I have drug say drug x and I think it
might inhibit this signaling pathway in
colon cancer. Uh, so what do I do
first? I get some colon cancer cells.
I expose it to the drug.
I see if it works in culture and this is
all called the discovery phase, right?
The next stage I might do if I find that
my drug works well in cultured cells
and I'm starting to uncover the molecular
mechanisms of how it works is tested
in animals.
I might take animals that
have colon cancer and try
to treat them with the drug.
And this is still in a discovery and
this is a phase called animal testing.
Now you begin to refine your approach.
You begin to refine your approach such
that you're starting to test not only for
the activity in animals because you
find that yes, your drug x does,
does uh,
is an effective treatment for cancer.
But you're trying to think
about what's the optimal dose,
how much dose would I need at this work?
The same way in people and
you start testing different
aspects of it in animals,
in preparation for testing and people.
So that's called that first step
in vitro is called lead discovery.
My lead drug is x. This is a
promising lead that I'm following.
And in animal testing
you do lead optimization.
But all of this takes a long time.
Could take four years from
the point that you think, ah,
maybe this drug is good too.
Yes,
I've shown that it really
is effective in animals.
Then a process of clinical testing
happens and the clinical testing occurs in
phases and in order to do testing
clinically you have to be approved by the
government to do that.
And in this country,
an organization called the
Food and Drug Administration,
the FDA is the only one that can give
you approval to take this test and
experimental medicine and people,
and they do that because you file
an application called an I and D or
investigational new drug application
and they look at all the data you've
collected over the last four
years and they say, yes,
you've convinced us that
this looks like a good drug.
It looks like it'll be safe.
You can go ahead and start testing it in
people and you first do small studies.
You deliver to a few people,
usually not people that have disease,
but people that don't have disease and
you deliver it in small doses and you
slowly increase the amount of dose that
you give them and what you're looking
for here is not effectiveness of the drug,
but you're looking for safety.
Is it safe and at what dose do
I begin to see side effects.
And this allows you to narrow in the range
that you're going to use in people to
test this drug for its effectiveness.
That's called phase one.
Phase two,
you start to look in patients that
have the disease in a small number of
patients, uh, to just look to see
if the drug is effective or not.
Phase one, you're asking
whether it's safe. In phase two,
you're asking if it's effective in the
patients that you would like to use it in.
And you do that in a small number of
patients first just because this is the
first time it's been used
to test effectiveness in
people and you're not quite
sure what's going to happen. And so you
do it in a small number of patients.
Just to show that it works the way that
you want and if it does work the way you
want,
you start phase three,
which is a very large clinical study that
is in the number of patients you need
to show that it is effective at
treating the kind of cancer you want.
How many patients are involved in studies
like this? What could be hundreds?
It could be thousands, depends on the
disease, how prevalent the disease is,
what the normal course of the disease is,
and how many patients you need to look
at in order to be absolutely sure that
you saw an effect that wasn't
just due to chance, right?
There's wasn't just due to chance,
and so these are very complicated
studies to do and hence very expensive.
Remember when we were
talking about vaccines,
we talked about a phase three study of
the polio vaccine that was invented by
Jonas Salk. How many patients were
involved in that clinical study?
Does anybody remember how many
patients were involved in that phase?
Three clinical study of the polio vaccine?
Who could remember that?
I remember 1.8 million a eight year
olds were involved in that study.
So clinical studies can be huge.
In the case of an infectious disease,
it's particularly large
number because you're,
you need to deliver it to enough people
to see a vaccine to see that you've
changed the uh,
the,
the incidents of disease within
a population. In cancer trials,
they tend to be hundreds or thousands
in size. If this space retrial works,
then you're allowed to sell the drug.
The FDA gives you permission to sell
the drug and for se for physicians to
prescribe it.
But this study doesn't end there and
that all manufacturers of drugs are
required to keep track of what happens
as their drug is introduced into the
population.
This is called phase four.
As physicians start
using it to treat cancer,
they're required to look
at how these things work.
And you will have noticed
in the, in the, um,
newspaper over the past few years,
some very famous drugs that turned
out to have side effects that weren't
expected after they were released into
the general population that once it
starts being used by physicians all over
the country in many, many more patients,
sometimes rare side effects appear
that we didn't expect before.
And so one continues to do research
and study even after that. So the,
the challenge for drug companies is
that this takes a very long time.
It takes a lot of money and there's
lots of places where your drug can fail.
Right? My drug x, which I described as
going neatly through in vitro studies,
animal testing, clinical testing might
have stopped working at some stage.
I might have found some problem with it.
Safety,
when I started testing
it in human volunteers,
I might've found that it didn't work
as well in animals as I expected it to
based on in vitro studies.
And people estimate that
for every 10,000 compounds,
10,000 x x's that are
thought of in laboratories,
only one of them eventually
gets approved by the FDA.
So this is why I drug development costs
so much money in this country cause you
have to look at a lot of compounds and
test them pretty extensively to find the
one that's really useful
for treating disease.
And I don't think we want to change that
because this process of FDA approval
was introduced early in this century
when people were selling drugs out of the
back of covered wagons and uh,
moving from town to town,
they're called snake
oil salesman or, or, um,
other things and people could sell
anything they want it and claim that it
treated a disease.
Now we have a very highly refined system
for asking people that are going to
sell drugs to prove that they work.
That system costs a lot of money.
There are,
there are opportunities I think for
biomedical engineers to improve how this
works by designing vet better
methods for in vitro study,
by using techniques we talked about
like in cell culture early on, uh, to,
to use those techniques more efficiently
to discover and test properties of
drugs.
And so this is going to be an area
where I think there's lots of growth and
opportunities in the
future. Just in closing, um,
I, uh, just put this website up there.
It's from science magazine, which is, uh,
which is a very high
profile scientific journal.
They published a poster which
is available online, uh,
that talks about sort of
modern develops in cancer,
modern developments in cancer
diagnosis and treatment.
I put a few sort of snapshots from that
poster into the PowerPoint presentation,
which will be available.
But I encourage you to go to this website
and look at this information and you
can find out more about what are the sort
of exciting pathways for the future in,
um, in, uh, biomedical
engineering and cancer treatment.
Great.
So I'll see you on Thursday.